[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry on
Francis Foster plan Constantine Kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
or the subjects they know nothing about
a trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts we ask the experts
we've done that long-winded introduction
but actually this is not an episode we
just wanted to say we've reached 10,000
subscribers on YouTube thank you so so
much for following us supporting us
watching the show if you've donated
money to us if you've been supporting us
on patreon we love you guys thank you so
much this is going to be a big year for
us in it it's gonna be a big year makes
me sad when you said it about 10,000 I
could have a little party popper oh no I
know I know thank you genuinely thank
you from the bottom of our hearts for
sharing for talking about it if you are
one of those people thinking isn't more
I could do please please please if you
can afford a little bit of money it will
help us to keep the show going that's
absolutely vital and we can get bigger
and better guests for you but on the
whole thank you so much we generally
can't do the show without you and seeing
our audience build and grow and people
discuss it is what makes us want to do
the show so thank you again thanks so
much guys and we will see you with the
next episode very very soon take care
[Music]
[Applause]